come you're thinking is the secret to
swarm success some of it is a cracking
ice glacier flows and a fair amount of
animals a lot of pissed off that there's
some birds some sea animals there she is
that's what all the fuss is about oil
it's kind of pretty is me oil coming up
out of the ground to make life a bit
more easy for all of us so the sounds
form is in networked Orchestra of boom
boxes and megaphones it's kind of a
noise orchestra that can play sounds to
two allies or enemies to create an
atmosphere of hostility or an atmosphere
of peace through sound design I asked
for people to submit sounds that they
might want the rural leaders to hear as
they're deciding the fate of the future
of the planet things they might want to
consider things that they might we need
to put in their ear I use some of those
and then I built a lot of new sounds
it's not explicitly illegal to make a
live soundtrack of the street for a
public protest
you